have you noticed ladies and gentlemen
there's a new thing in motion pictures
now they take the titles of the pictures
and they turn them into songs now you
just heard friendly persuasion that was
from friendly persuasion
now there's written on the wind but I
got to tell you who's from Whitten on
the wind written there's a new song I
heard today that's based also on a
motion picture a very beautiful thing
that's entitled Mon pot kettle meet
Frankenstein it's a wall and now on this
big hill here for the VGO booze mafia oh
yeah they did we present a very lovely
lady a very very gifted artist a very
very wonderful performer and a former
Academy Award winner Miss Eva Marie
Saint
how are you eating you look beautiful
and how is your beautiful baby I'm here
you're about to become a father again
yep daddy and I roll the panthan of no.1
and I've been out buying baby clothes
like crazy I've been buying baby clothes
me yeah well girls clothes and the only
reason I'm buying them is because I'm
too nervous to mint but I'd like to
explain it the reason I'm buying the
clothes because it's a wonderful thing
and I'm looking forward to like you know
a child and I'm getting Pinklon little
dresses and aprons and petticoats and
cute little kinds of things like that
supposing it's a boy
he'll way to dresses and I'll teach him
how to fight that's all
the nominations for Best Music score of
a dramatic for comedy picture are Alfred
Newman for Anastasia Victor young for
around the world in 80 days you go free
to offer for between heaven and hell to
meet Rick Tompkins for giant and Alex
North for the Rainmaker now at the
envelope
the winner is Victor Yeung
I'd like to thank you so much on behalf
of the late great Victor Young and his
family and I'd like to say that I think
this is the most wonderful thing that
the industry has done thank you thank
you very much and even Thank You Liz for
accepting to announce the winner of the
best scoring of musical picture the
Academy sent a camera crew abroad to
capture a gentleman who is in the Oscar
race for Best Performance by an actor he
is one of the stars of giant mr. Rock
Hudson okay let's get out the film on
rock and roll film on rock and roll
hello you're looking at a fellow whose
heart is right there with all of you at
the Pantages Theatre tonight for more
reasons than one but instead here I am
in a little spot called misery nough in
the heart of the dolomite mountains in
Italy we're on this very day we are
starting a little picture called The
Farewell to Arms I tried to get them to
change the location from misery nough to
the corner of yucca and Argyle but
somehow it isn't quite the same so one
of the things I was looking forward to
this evening was the opportunity of
presenting the award for the best
scoring of a musical picture and there
were plenty of them this year the
nominees are
Lionel Newman for the best things in
life are free
Morris stole off and George Dunning for
the Eddy Duchin story Johnny green and
Saul Chaplin for high society Alfred
Newman and Ken Darby for the King and I
George Stoll and Johnny green or meet me
in Las Vegas now let's open the envelope
and see which of these greatly talented
people is the winner the winner is the
King and I Alfred Newman and Ken Darby
thank you so much thank you again
congratu congratulations Alfred and Ken